welcome welcome to your mom's house
Christina the gypsies pretty and by the
way where do you find that the the way
you sent me how'd you get a hold of yet
yeah today Wow okay you're right babe
it's probably the worst moment in the
history of the show right now it's
probably the worst moment ever in the
history of your mom's house just
listening to you doing it yeah so so
check this out okay thanks man
so I did that on local press in
Cleveland and then this morning this
comes on just comes in to us and just
tell me what you did of this shit oh
shit yeah that's the right answer
you got it
so shout out to everybody doing their
claim it's rockin week in the house
roxeanne beatboxing productions the best
boxing promoted the 209 has to offer
shout out to the Diaz boys if you boys
ever want to step up to a real promoter
way too fucking long but here's the
thing that happens about this guy talks
for a while talks last shit you know you
won't talk some shit and then after a
little bit of a house am i right so you
have now awoken of for so great that it
cannot be restrained this is your girl
like I said you have rattled the Lions
pain oh shit I know what you think he's
got in there crazy looks oh no no you
ain't talking about me and stuff like
that she will get it cracking and stuff
like that let's get it cracking at a gym
and stuff like ya know retail store get
on some flowers and stuff like that
hey fine cracking and stuff like that
you feel me
for reals though let's get it on that
this channel 8 and stock girl oh you got
channel a crazy notes he's ready to step
up and step in the ring
okay whatever wait you think you're
ready a crazy notes can't be ready he is
finished level his car to you damn is
here black eyes
where is that paint no it's hmm doesn't
it look like black guys it's an iron
deficiency okay this is amazing this
amazing this guy found crazy looks he
did this guy was at my show sacrament
and did he give you a heads up like hey
yeah he was like one of the front row
guys that I talked to you know like
throughout that show and then he went
and found crazy low this is yeah his
dedication in his knowledge of boxing
it's more than his real finger then
you've got to do rather large and
serious okay so she will await your
answer crazy don't what else you got for
the man I'll take you out and I'll take
your wife and she'll goes out to Tom
Segura and she'll go dr. Christina a bye
god bless we all keep it pushin that's
the eye strain you know we got even
talking mess about us over North Carroll
prisoners we got to concentrate now you
gotta keep it pushin but I gotta keep it
pushing one of the greatest moments of
my life
crazy crazy look just made it crazy this
is so crazy this has never happened like
we never get to get this far with our um
you know our subjects yes yeah this is
amazing
uh what's gonna happen are we gonna do
this well there's a little more okay
shout out to everybody doing their
things and rocking me and for crazy
knows mrs. Segura we're going to await
your answer well we have to come to
SoCal or whether you like to come up to
Northern California to the ghetto as you
have requested with him let's get how I
refer to it I don't know it cracking
that's what I'm talking about we're
ready sure we'll be waiting and got no
response
golly buddy got this Buddha governs
everybody doing their thing
alright pull my rap on the way out
pressure loads from the mic I straight
to us alright I doing so good hope you
understand I keep it so true when I
speak no fear what I said I straight to
it finally here from the temple front of
brain Christian Lopes is a thug it's
gonna maintain in every way no play ok
so yeah I'm sorry I'm just processing it
I don't like I clear my brain can't
comprehend it so this dude on the right
owns a restaurant and that came up
during the show many ways he was like
we're just talking about that and then I
think it was I forget how far it is from
I think he said he just drove two hours
to meet Crazy Legs oh my god so at the
end of this video because this ends here
pretty quickly right yeah and then it's
like it's just him making a video that
he actually shot on the way to meet
crazy Lok's
so I guess he took to heart the you know
the part where before I was saying we
could do we could get together and sell
tickets and do a charity thing he is
suggesting we do one for mental health
awareness hey that's great let's do it
well we just have to figure out what
exactly are we selling tickets to that's
really out to you Segura I know I mean
he said I could spar him but I mean come
on I don't know is that really is that a
good idea
yeah let's let's marinate on this a
moment maybe DJing challenge but lokes
isn't a DJ he's a rapper hello
so you want to do a show with him hello
yes obviously I named the greatest
rappers one of gray's DJ's alive
oh my gather do you think you could sell
tickets and I think to our fans we could
man see you're donating to charity
you're not selling tickets to you know
actually for what your watch so you want
to do in a NorCal or SoCal well dude
NorCal I think that's an idea I'm not
saying it's set in stone but I think
it's a good idea okay where's another
idea okay hear me out
why don't we do
a fucking your mom's house podcast live
oh yeah and invite crazy looks down and
do that make it like a fucking massive
your mom's house event that's a good
idea and then maybe the big finale is
you and crazy looks deejaying and you
guys can kind of prepare and you know
yeah and we could that will be really
crazy crazier than crazy crazy like
crazy looks what do you think so kind a
good idea and we can get a huge venue I
think it'll be Orca NorCal know so Carol
do it down here
then you gotta bring crazy Lopes down
dude we go up there okay we'll see
that's what I think we do I think we'd
go up there and do it okay because you
could also everybody we could we could
you know invite the every Sacramento
listener every San Jose list under this
code could come out - alright shit big
thing look let's let's I think that's a
great idea that'd be really fun know how
much we have to donate to charity yeah
we could do that really good